- Tons and tons of people are upset
that the COVID relief bill
has a bunch of extra spending in it.
Pork barrel spending on things
unrelated to COVID relief.
Why should a COVID bill have earmarks
for higher education and foreign aid?
It doesn't make sense.
Well, it actually does
because this isn't really a COVID bill,
for various procedural reasons
I'm not going to go into,
this is actually a spending bill
that happens to have a
COVID bill attached to it.
This is a bill that
funds the U.S. government
through September of 2021.
$1.4 trillion to keep
the government running.
And for various arcane procedural reasons,
it made sense to add the $900
million COVID relief bill
onto the $1.4 trillion spending bill.
So this isn't a COVID bill
with a bunch of extra spending.
It's a spending bill with a
bunch of extra COVID stuff.
And if you'd like even
more legal analysis,
check out my real law reviews
where I tackle all the
legal news of the day,
and I'll see you in court.